los gobiernos ya definen fechas para
inmunizar a sus poblaciones en eeuu la
agencia de alimentos y medicamentos se
reunirá el 10 de diciembre para decidir
si aprueba la vacuna desarrollada por la
farmacéutica pfiezer que mostró un 95
por ciento de eficacia contra el virus
según un asesor del programa de
vacunación del gobierno éste podría
empezar el 12 de diciembre tendremos las
primeras vacunas distribuidas un día
después de la aprobación y esperamos que
la gente pueda empezar a ser inmunizada
diría que en las 48 horas siguientes a
la aprobación antes que eeuu reino unido
podría ser el primero en aprobar dicha
vacuna citando a fuentes del gobierno
del sitio de noticias the telegraph dijo
que podría ser aprobada esta misma
semana sin embargo el presidente del
gobierno español pedro sánchez dijo que
junto a alemania serán los primeros
países de la unión europea en tener un
plan completo de vacunación y prevé que
se ponga en marcha en enero de 2021
habrá una parte muy sustancial de la
población podrá ser vacunada con todas
las garantías a lo largo del primer
semestre de 2021 se va a contar con 13
mil puntos de vacunación otra candidata
vacuna
tiene la atención del mundo es la
desarrollada por moderna cuya
efectividad es de un 94 por ciento según
el director ejecutivo de la farmacéutica
ésta cobrará a los gobiernos entre 25 y
37 dólares por dosis